what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are back to continue the bad batch
episode three today I'm here with my buddy
we got a really great response last time you
earned your spot back here at the recheck
Nation Michaels my Star Wars nerdy friend
Michael tesler who by the way I forgot to
mention this last time he actually has a really
up and coming some might say it's already
come and become successful I don't care right
it's called multi-house you guys should go
check it out you got an Instagram page yeah
we sure do yeah website at multi house I O
plug it and that's our website and that's
also our Instagram handle good stuff so yeah
we do all different sorts of uh going over
some multi-platform storytelling I know how
to sell the sizzle come on everything is inspired
by Star Wars
leave a like people leave a like that would
be very much appreciated helps this video
out as always full and stretch and watch long
story stick with your own copy of the bad
match available for super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page come over there to see what
else we check out exclusively reaction Hots
and Watch Dogs included Michael Tesla are
you ready oh you know what last Sunday I prayed
at the altar of Dave filoni you know this
to be a great episode and it's gonna be the
best I'm so excited episode three let's go
what's this episode called oh I'm ready clone
Cody Cody he's in the trailers where are we
I love Interstellar such a good movie yeah
look at all that corn
one Final Approach governor
homeboy looks tense
I'm
really enjoying the mood of this episode already
yeah right
I love their armor I am here to relieve you
of your title mistress Ames by order of the
Galactic Empire as I have told your government
Essex does not fall under Imperial jurisdiction
take your forces and leave your request has
been received reviewed and as you can see
rejected how disappointing
oh ran around here Roger Roger I have a message
for your Empire
what was the message [Laughter] [Music] that
bed does not look comfortable no
foreign
I heard the defense recruitment bill is up
for a vote again let's hope it doesn't pass
for our sake
oh
he's a real reject
oh foreign
[Music] immediately
it's so solemn now I know what are my orders
the Imperial Governor has been taken hostage
by insurgents demanding desex be recognized
as an independent Planet fools what Squad
will I be leading you're not ready to play
Commander again your new Commander will brief
you on the details Cody
those might be some aggressive negotiations
I love this like Vietnam memorial wall of
foreign it's been a while good to see you
Commander Cody
the paint job when I heard you were cleared
for Duty I requested you specifically the
rest of Clone Force 99 went rogue after Order
66 came through surprised rumors are more
and more clones a pin questioning the order
clone Rebellion like the Jedi [Music] good
soldiers follow orders
God those words are haunting seize the city
and taken Governor Groton hostage the insurgents
are expecting a diplomatic Envoy catch them
by surprise Wipe Out the droids and locate
Governor Groton sounds easy enough I love
seeing Cody back Imperial shuttle 995 requesting
permission to enter desk access base granted
you are cleared for approach
I love this planet it is gorgeous he knew
the Republic was corrupt that it would collapse
and become something worse a Galactic Empire
you will lose this as well it's an attractive
ass leader right there
let's welcome them shall we it looks like
they've chosen not to negotiate this guy seems
so cowardly how did he get to this position
that's a great question there's a lot of planets
a lot of job opportunities move into position
it's probably tarkin's nephew it's a nepotism
rule space nepotism
oh boy
God I've missed the droids the Imperial vessel
has been neutralized and crashed in sector
five send Scouts to the wreck check for any
survivors yes Governor this reminds me of
like the 2004 Clone Wars like early animation
when they crash in the city
that doesn't look good yeah for them we found
the shuttle there are no survivors barely
scoped it out man
is it just trust those two
Notch we'll have to oh there's a bunch of
them the squad's two engine to continue crosshairs
trust me you do make things interesting
this is cool this feels like a classic Clone
Wars episode but they're the Clones are bad
it's interesting
whatever clever aim at certain spots that
they're off at same right into the eye
God I forgot how badass he is he was literally
in a Crosshair
[Music]
[Music] [Applause] Professor got more shots
in a row than any Stormtrooper in all of A
New Hope yeah [Music] thank you I've always
loved when they fought the droids because
you can get away with more violence oh so
much violence Nova you're with us we'll take
the north axis team two take this out don't
split their assault recommend protocol four
see it done I'll secure grunt man I would
have planted like Claymore mines everywhere
a lot of running [Music] good call okay
it's okay we're here to help [Laughter] [Music]
him
yes I love them
[Music] [Applause]
ah nice nice nice
[Music]
the plane this is a really cool episode yeah
so far so good
[Music] [Applause] damn they're just messing
[__] up [Applause]
so I can't get a clear line of sight let's
remedies
foreign
[Music]
[Music] [Laughter]
oh man oh [__] heesh secure the tower
[Music] oh [__] ah yeah
[Music]
dude I mean they're not on the right side
but I have Rudy for them
[Music] they're learning oh no oh
vibroblood right there he used a knife
I'll take out the tech Droid I can make the
shot from here give me a line of sight I'm
worried about Cody everybody's just gonna
kill them off I think they have to right right
now well not right now but [Music] oh
awesome
that was great
oh [__]
nice shot
worried about Cody cross her gonna do it we
are an independent system we're not here to
debate politics with you your droid army have
attacked two Imperial convoys we were defending
ourselves [Laughter]
we are not the enemy the Empire seeks to establish
peace and Order throughout the Galaxy you
believe that Cody there was a time I believed
in that so much so my colleague Mina bonteri
and I put forth a treaty with secretary that's
reference your Supreme Chancellor rejected
it I realized then peace was never an option
uh-oh it might be a Crosshair it's an option
now we both live through one war let's not
start another too many people have died already
mainly droids do this for your people
wow Cody now execute her sir I promised a
peaceful you did I didn't now execute her
you [__] I gave you an order follow it
or face the consequences for discipline [Applause]
cold-hearted guy yeah
oh that tune
put a body in the Square let it be a warning
to the rest of them are you sniveling snake
something tells me Cody's gonna have a character
r ude I love that I think we might really
get a clone Rebellion [Music] I know but what's
Rector up to I don't know
I kind of wish this was the first episode
yeah right
this is what I've been waiting for foreign
gets to reunite with Rex yeah I hope so
so fun and interesting watching the Clones
just slowly become more and more relevant
we're soldiers we do what needs to be done
you know it makes us different from battle
droids Choice our own choices
we have to live with him too [Music]
it's cool how when they first met they were
on different sides and yeah this last conversation
slipped even he looks in Conflict too yeah
he's gonna attack text Hunter yeah hey Rob
after your success on desex I'm entrusting
you with another mission report to cc1226
why not Commander Cody cc2224 it appears he
has gone a war what loyalty does not seem
to be as advertised anymore no way are these
clones around you keep disappearing
no sir then you're dismissed
crosshairs like I'm just trying to be a good
soldier yeah I'm getting blamed for everyone
[__] I guess he is the solitary clone
[Music]
[Music] that was great what great that was
a great episode great great content man that
was good content I for my Star Wars brain
yeah I love love love watching this like descent
of the Clones and like being forced to come
to terms with the reality of their actions
uh with Order 66 and like you know I I they're
definitely setting something up major uh which
I'm just I'm so jazzed about it I know that
was awesome I like that way more than the
first two episodes I just love the I love
the Sinister tone and how the conflict seems
to just have a a switcher room because when's
the last time we saw Cody was was it like
in terms of timeline for us was it episode
three it was episode three I mean he he had
just shot Kenobi down uh and and then he was
on the hunt for him and and that was that
for Cody uh which like you know in in Clone
Wars they built that relationship up so much
which just made the payoff in episode three
like all the more devastating you know I can't
even imagine in in the same way that that
you know Ahsoka directs I feel like you know
Obi-Wan was the Cody yeah um and it really
like it's it's nice to see them going AWOL
I just how do you think the chips are gonna
feed into everything like and like the consequences
of I guess how much control do you think the
Empire still has over the Clones it looks
like it's looks like the battery life on the
chips are
he's a recharge it seems like to me but just
the philosophical discussions and just how
nuanced and ridiculously complex it is to
pair up both Crosshair who we saw at the end
of last season who is in a constant like are
you gonna be good or not you know yeah yeah
but we're always wondering that with him especially
for the fact that he let them live in at the
end of uh the first season who's obviously
still in some type of conflict over the whole
thing it seems like more often than not he's
gonna just follow orders and do the executions
do what he needs to be done but to pair him
up with Cody based off I mean going off like
everything that you were just saying yeah
about Cody but having like these little reminders
because it's been a while since we've seen
Cody but there's this like gap of History
here with Cody that we haven't seen from Order
66 to now where it seems like there has been
a toll that's been taken on him and that's
the moment in time we're meeting up with him
because when he says that line about like
their Traders like the Jedi you could just
see that that trauma yeah the pain like did
I make the right choice yeah and is it even
really a choice you know and I think even
being cognitively aware you know I mean even
as like the rumors among the Clones of the
existence of the chips because that's the
other question does Cody even know that he
has a Jeb um I don't think he does most people
most of them didn't know and I but I feel
like that that creates such an interesting
kind of you know as they talk about like the
Clone Rebellion uh that's kind of I think
is what we're actually building up to this
season um it would certainly explain what
happened to all the Clones uh because I'm
tripping me you put a gold damn chip in me
reckon uh no but you're you're absolutely
right um uh yeah I'm just like it's it's brilliant
watching the Clones be stripped of their individuality
like they started the episode showing Cody
instead of his signature yellow which like
I still have my Cody action figure back home
like uh to to put him into this like gray
and to take it away where Crosser didn't even
recognize him at first and then at the tail
end of the episode Crosshair uses his actual
name Cody instead of his you know his his
CC uh signature uh and the fact that the imperial
you know the vice admiral didn't even like
acknowledge that or uh just it kind of goes
to show that you know the the Empire is um
it doesn't want to run the risk of individual
thought because individual thought and any
kind of you know utilitarian Society is risky
and dangerous uh I agree you know so oh yeah
definitely I feel like our country should
be more that way no idea listen it's got to
stop letting people make choices I feel like
if we had more you know like what they do
in like North Korea where you get eight haircuts
simple it's working out for the Clones every
day Steve Jobs wore the same shirt yeah that's
all I'm saying it's it's decision fatigue
uh no it's it's also it's also cool I appreciate
that they're using different helmet and armor
it's what it's called Uh I appreciate that
they're they're using different armor types
to distinguish and kind of give us a visual
sense of things are shifting in terms of look
at these non-clone uh Storm Troopers um so
yeah yeah good point it's a good point uh
and it was really really kind of omnipresent
this episode whereas in the first two episodes
I don't think we saw any just yet and I bet
as the season progresses clones are gonna
start mysteriously kind of fading out well
I what I really really appreciate about this
particular episode was it felt like a classic
Clone Wars episode but the ironic sense that
you're not watching the Clones fight on the
right side and I thought that was fascinating
because you're like kind of with them they're
like they're like kicking ass and shooting
droids and [__] but if they were like
people yeah it would be so messed up but that's
that's the trick they were playing on us though
yeah and they got both of us yeah because
they're like cool cool they're fighting for
the Empire yeah yeah and and I think that's
the Brilliance of the Poetry of of this episode
it Rhymes it does it does George Lucas knew
what he was talking about from the beginning
it's all connected Dr Seuss uh no it's uh
yeah uh all the Clones down in cloneville
uh not it's so great to you know I thought
like the final season of Clone Wars minus
like the first two or three episodes were
like just some of the best animated content
I've ever seen in my entire life and the final
episodes were like some of the best Star Wars
yeah yeah I mean it and it it holds up uh
because I re-watch it every night
I wish I was kidding uh but this this was
great because it does feel like that continuation
um whereas when we follow the rest of the
bad batch the tone and and the feel feels
a bit more like Rebels um where it's a bit
lighter it's a bit it's a bit more fun that's
kind of the point though of this show isn't
it it's a bit of a it's a connective thread
between Clone Wars the rebels yeah which which
is beautiful um and and I still prefer this
yeah I mean but dark Booty Star Wars is the
best yeah yeah are you on antidepressants
you'll probably you'll probably like this
side of things uh no it's it's definitely
it's really interesting watching them try
to navigate that in a way that that makes
sense um and I really I feel like a clone
Rebellion is the perfect way like how do we
get all these players back in the same place
at the same time yeah um they're reused uh
and the Clone Rebellion you know or I guess
you know what's the difference between a rebellion
or a revolution you know rebellions fail uh
uh so it'll be interesting to kind of watch
I mean they all have to die right like I mean
that's how this you know when in Rebels we
really only pick up with with Rex Gregor wolf
and Gregor um you know where's Cody where's
the rest of the the band you know so it cloneville
I wanna we should write that uh I got a sliding
pool
how the clankers Stole Christmas you walk
in you're like which one's which can't tell
them apart are you clone racist Greg a little
bit a little bit yeah I almost got excited
at Cody when uh you know the when across here
what's up in the cafeteria but like I'm not
sure if that's code is that Cody nah you're
just a racist
I don't care what you're saying it's it's
definitely nice to know that clone lunch time
is just like Middle School
like God these guys that they fought wars
together they've been through all this stuff
and they won't even like they're still gonna
bully the little little bad batch but oh yeah
that was a great episode I loved it I I love
that one that made me really happy Yeah I'm
I'm I'm curious you know for for the you know
the reject Nation what do you guys think is
how are they going to bring all these characters
back into the same place because that's what
I'm trying to are you trying to trade engagement
with the audience I well I I they were so
nice to me they they said nice things it's
a whole thing where you ask the audience a
question of something to respond to in the
comments yeah well it's it's just you know
I I don't remember who said it but somebody
in the comments brought up the Clone rebellion
and I when I first read it I was like nah
they're not gonna do that this season and
uh well you were right I think um I think
I think this time gets like season seven a
bad batch I want I want to follow the bad
batch at their like really nice retirement
home on Alderaan yeah and they're like man
we finally did it finally finally settling
down and then I want the Death Star to shoot
down and I want it to end with I want them
all to make it but just uh you know they died
like a car crash or something yeah something
like like what you wouldn't like I I want
to see like like Wrecker or Tech I want to
see Tech OD on death sticks [Laughter]
thanks guys for being here leave a like follow
Michael president CEO dictator of multi-house
individuality is a recipe for disaster that's
where mission statement is uh reject Nation
May the force be with you thanks for having
me as always we've got to end this with a
patron of the day shout out oh uh well we
have a
Andrew Hayes Andrew you've been a patron of
ours for many years now I know a long time
six years is going on I was gonna say you
were in diapers back then like no I was a
child and now I'm thinking that it would be
great if I could clone more people like you
if I could just clone an Andrew Hayes and
if I could just have a patreon page full of
nothing but Andrew Hayes's you haven't met
Andrew I love Andrew he's a short like stocky
guy like from New Jersey hey no I'm from Long
Island he's and imagine just a bunch of them
and what's great about Andrew is I haven't
heard from him in like a year yeah I think
his card is just on file and he completely
forgot to remember God uh Andrew Endor uh
his bank uh if you have a complaint he's also
one of our highest punishments I'm convinced
he's just left it out of his credit card I've
heard from this guy in so long and he's just
here he still does it and I love him so much
what a sweet guy what if what if he died um
what what if what if just nobody knows how
to turn it off ignorance is bliss is what
I say well Andrew uh you're a real MVP you're
a really is man includes his reputation to
keep your car on file whatever for however
long you're great thank you for the love Andrew
uh Greg really appreciates it I do I thought
there's more to that sentence uh yeah I do
appreciate it buddy and you are an amazing
soul and I hope I hope I hear from you properly
soon happy New Year bud happy New Year [Music]